vous avez parlé de vérité officielle il
n'y a pas de vérité officielle il ya une
vérité lorsqu'on témoigne sous serment
et moi je peux vous assurer que monsieur
benalla n'a pas exercé de missions de
police
il se trouve que je sais un petit peu ce
que c'est qu'une mission de police
puisque je l'exercé 3 ans en cabinet du
directeur général de la police nationale
mais voyez je vous demande pas de vous
mettre notre place mais il ya des
éléments contradictoires et j'entends
bien ce que vous dites et j'entends
aussi votre sincérité mais les préfets
de police quand il délivre un permis de
port d'armes
il le fait bien sur la base des
informations qui lui ont été données par
l'elysée et qu'est ce qu'il écrit il le
relève un certain nombre de considérants
parmi lesquels je lis ceci considérant
que monsieur benalla est chargé d'une
mission de police dans le cadre de son
action de coordination de la sécurité de
la présidence de la république avec les
forces militaires et le gspr donc
peut-être que nous entendons mal sur les
mots mais en tous les cas il a bien
fallu que l'elysée dit au préfet de
police il a une mission de police sinon
il n'aurait pas eu du port d'armes
mais également on peut se dire pourquoi
a t'on demandé à trois reprises avant de
l'obtenir un permis de port d'armes pour
monsieur benalla si il n'a strictement
aucune fonction de sécurité
et je rappelle d'ailleurs que le métier
de monsieur benalla avant d'entrer la
présidence de la république est
exclusivement un métier de sécurité
c'est sa spécialité c'est ce qu'il a
appris et c'est son expérience
professionnelle et mettez vous à la
place de nos concitoyens comme de
nous-mêmes non une commission d' enquête
pour savoir les choses clairement et et
il est mais pour nous difficile de
comprendre la réalité des choses quand
nous sommes en présence de
contradictions et j'ai bien entendu ce
que vous avez dit est ce que vous avez
dit répond à une logique d'organisation
qui est tout à fait souhaitable mais
voyez c'est c'est eh voyez nous avons
des éléments qui sont sur notre table
monsieur loges alors je maintiens
évidemment mais mes propos je ne suis
pas le rédacteur de ce texte
réglementaire pris par le préfet de
police vous l'avez interrogé peut-être
rien
il faut peut-être le réinterroger mais
sur ce premier point
cuisez mois mais qui a demandé le permis
pour rien je je je crois que patrick
strzoda a été très très clairs là dessus
c'est lui qui a été en contact avec la
préfecture de police sur ce sujet là
pour quoi faire
non mais c'est lui qui a été en contact
avec la préfecture de police sur ce
sujet là il a demandé et je vous prie de
de reprendre les propos qu'il a tenus
devant cette commission
il a demandé à la préfecture de police
d'analyser cette demande dans les règles
de droit voilà pour mon cas personnel
dont cas personnel cette demande
cette demande
de port d'armes dans le cas d'espèce
fondée sur des questions de sécurité
donc à différencier d'une protection
personnelle n'a pas transité par mes
mains donc essais et je m'en explique et
c'est normal puisque les questions de
sécurité sont traitées directement sous
l'autorité du directeur de cabinet donc
je ne peux pas vous répondre plus avant
moi je ne sais ce que je peux vous
contenter de vous dire et là aussi en
restant à la place qui est la mienne qui
est celle de chef de cabinet c'est
l'émission que j'ai conférer à monsieur
benalla et je voulais expliquer je crois
en détail faîtière forme et qu'il
bénéficiait d'un port d'armes
oui j'en ai été informé et vous demande
de prendre son arme dont certaines
missions il a aussi je vais être très
clair comme je crois vous le deal
général lavernhe je n'ai jamais vu
monsieur bien là avec son arme sur une
mission du président de la république
est en tous les cas pour les missions
qui sont les missions officielles je ne
l'aurais pas accepté puisque la sécurité
du président de la république est
assurée par ailleurs par le j'espère et
par les forces de police et de
gendarmerie mobilisées sous l'autorité
des préfets